I'm judging the [ __ ] out of you on your
tattoo choice how many tattoos I have is
equal to how many annoying questions
you're going to ask me this session will
it hurt what hurts is you missed the 10
signs at the front of the studio
demanding that you don't ask me that
question I definitely didn't spellcheck
this before I started tattooing up
today's do a good job so yep three years
of art school just to tattoo countless
southern crosses on pasty white guy's
biceps be nice to me and I'll be nice to
your intricate outline are you sure
you're not drunk I kind of wish you were
cuz that tattoo design is really bad a
tattoo of a woman crying what a great
idea
it's men like you that make this all
worthwhile ah your first tattoo remind
me again why I should care how long will
it take well that depends do you want
this tattoo of your daughter to look
like a smiley face are you gonna let me
do my job your call buddy
another drunk guys bare ass cheek is it
my birthday or did mine hurt her who
tattooists are a superior alien
life-form completely immune to thousands
of needles piercing through the skin now
it's your turn
you think it's too expensive I think my
time is - see ya